[Music]
hey there folks time once again for a
matinee show our three new movies now
what ended up happening this week um
actually three movie started in the
theater that we wanted to see but
because this week also featured a
RiffTrax live yeah we had to go see that
we weren't gonna miss that because you
know you guys know why we don't get that
all that [ __ ] you don't get that on the
AMC yeah you got to pay for that Stubbs
deal you got to pay for it but they're
worth it it's a live show and the crowds
good and original - yeah so we
definitely wanted to see that so it
turned out that like a lot of the new
movies that started started on Thursday
night and that was also on Thursday
night and it didn't work out with the
times because it started like an yeah at
like an off time so we didn't get to see
any of the new movies in theaters so we
just saw the RIP tracks and then we just
watched two new ones on Netflix there is
a whole lot of new ones come probably
next week we have three um in so
probably next week's matinee show will
probably be three in the theater because
there are three starting that we had
actually kind of wanted to see which
ones of it um I can't remember what they
are offhand but I remember like writing
it down I think it was like good boys
and that one about the Bruce Springsteen
kid yeah yeah there was like one other
one that I can't remember all right yeah
so we'll probably see those next week
but this week we did to Netflix ones and
retract so the first one we're gonna
talk about is called girls with the
balls yeah yeah that's good on Netflix
yeah and it's it's a French movie yeah
but you can tell what they're doing is
they're trying to take it back to an
old-school 80s American movie yeah
there's a lot of English signs where
they were going and they were in a
camper and the the the volleyball girls
their uniforms look like an American
uniform to me kind I thought they were
trying to make it look as an American as
possible and I cuz I think that was the
genre yeah and he even had like the the
narrator was dressed as a [ __ ] cow as
a cowboy yeah yeah this [ __ ] this shit's
awesome it's got a good it's got a real
good tone it's kind of like scream when
you say maybe maybe a little funnier
this well this is kind of like okay
imagine if the hills have I was a comedy
like a super zany like
over-the-top comedy yes with but also
French yeah if you can imagine that
you'll imagine the tone of it it's very
manic it's very crazy
yeah um its gory like a lot of French
yes films are he in French with English
subject yeah we didn't bother with the
double yeah don't bother these [ __ ]
doves man because they always suck and
it [ __ ] up a tone of the movie
there's not a whole lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
going on
you know intellectually it's a very
simple story like I said but I can tell
you the the the jokes are gonna
translate a lot better and with
subtitles yes they do you're not gonna
be able to do this right Doug
cuz like I said it's funny because when
this cuz this movie first popped up on
Netflix I think it premiered it likes at
the European like fantastic Film
Festival or something like in 2018 but
Netflix just put it up probably only a
couple weeks ago and it's funny because
when you're not looking in the specific
horror movie section if you just see the
little title card for it like in the
recently added it didn't occur to me
that it was a horror movie because it
doesn't look like a horror no it looks
like looks like a comedy it looks like a
comedy which it is but it does have a
gory though it is very good very sexual
- it's very yeah yeah it's just the it
has like this vulgar lay it bottom it's
very 80s like I said and all it is it's
this it's this volleyball team called
the Falcons a [ __ ] high school girl
knowledge it's hard to tell I think
they're supposed to be high school girls
but they're obviously 25 years old so
like they do that a lot in American
movies like yeah all the high school
students like they all look yeah they're
a real rocket ship yes so it's like so
they're going out I think now you'd look
this up and you said that it was shot
it's not shot in France it's shot like
that mostly in Spain I think it's
Tenerife in Tenerife that's in the
Canary Islands Spain
well Spain is the Canary Islands say
Canary okay well I remember that I'm
looking at it and I'm going man that
terrain that's California it's not a big
calf when it's gonna be California well
that's when they filmed all the
spaghetti westerns because California
they're so yeah it does look like it's
shot in Tenerife so I don't know did
they even explain like where they were
going I thought they were going to like
the championships or
something like that it doesn't really
matter they just get stranded out in a
damn woods in this [ __ ] camper and
they get attacked by what a group of
what you would call here in the US
[ __ ] Cajuns which is like the French
hillbilly yeah they call them
Hillbillies but instead they're calling
hillbillies here in Louisiana you'd call
them a bunch of Cajuns yeah they are a
[ __ ] something like and they're kind
of like pirates
descendants of pirates of it they look
like pirates kind of not really they
kind of look like someone review said
they look kind of like Tusken Raiders
but like a redneck from rags tied over
their head you know with the holes cut
in it which in a way if you go back to
southern history that in the area of
Louise Louisiana and stuff a lot of
Raiders and [ __ ] kook Klansmen was
just a damn white bag tied over their
heads with holes cut for the eyes and
they were wearing that on top old suits
and old 18-hundreds pepperbox pistols
crossbows I think they were look like
single-shot shotguns and things like
that
just kind of archaic weapons yeah and
they were like a cult
inbred cult that had this religion and
they I guess their religions kind of
kind of was kind of circled around
cutting girls heads off they had a lot
of girls heads yeah yeah it is so kind
of yeah it was kind of like a Cthulhu
cult or something they were yeah they
didn't really go a lot into that didn't
matter but they had it had some cult
trappings to it but like I said it was
kind of like it reminded me a little bit
of The Hills Have Eyes if The Hills Have
Eyes was an over-the-top French comment
yeah but there's like like I said now
this is gonna be like I feel like I've
seen reviews that were like really
really good or really really bad like a
lot of people didn't like it like for
some reason a lot of British reviews
they really loved it
I think the best review American review
was like in the Los Angeles Times I
think they thought it was great and a
lot of horror sites really liked it too
now you have to know like what you're
getting into if you're just expecting it
to be a straight horror movie or a
modern horror movie it's not like that
it's it's a throwback and it's very very
zany it's very very versus this [ __ ]
happens in this like the girls they're a
volleyball team so it's like they'll
throw volleyballs of people there's like
blood flies everywhere like there
late in the volleyballs and stuff but
it's like it's just one that you just
relax and that let it happen
imagine if hills has a have eyes was
French and it was army of darkness his
army a darkness real close yeah there's
like there's people's heads getting shot
off there's just like we're doing like
people getting holes blown - it's like
ash vs. Evil Dead yeah it's cartoonish
but in a good way like you know like a
guy picks up a little dog and like
stretches this way
yeah and [ __ ] like that it's just this
crazy like ash vs. Evil Dead you'll like
it yeah I imagine it's the same tone
pretty much yeah and like I said it's
you know it had some good gore in it the
characters were good and actually there
was um there was a little bit of like
tension like in the team because there
was like all these rivalries like
between all the women on the team like
one of one of the ones I think her name
was Morgan and she was like a real
backstabbing [ __ ] and then it was one
girl who was like the nerdy fat so I'm
like oh she must only be fat by French
standards yeah he's really and she had
glasses and was like kind of a
volleyball team they were physically fit
she just kind of has kind she was just
kind of nerdy looking yeah and like she
you know steps up and ends up being like
all heroic and stuff but it's like it's
so much hotties unless yes ISM and
sluttiness and it's it has that teen
tiene element of 80s [ __ ] slasher yeah
but I'm talking cheek about it yes not
realistic but also kind of cool because
it's just kind of like this team of
girls and like kicks ass against all
these like creepy ass dudes that like
try it and eventually they get killed
though - I mean yeah it's a lot some of
them do get killed it's you know it's
pretty cool and what and I really like
probably one of one of my favorite
aspects of it is like you said the guy
who's like he's like a bard he's like a
singer at the very beginning and he's
dressed like it like an American cowboy
except like with fringe and yeah a real
cowboy about a real cowboy it's like
holy cow
and he's like singing a song pretty much
exactly about exactly what's gonna
happen like in the rest of the movie
he's like a Greek chorus kind of thing
where he's like commenting on the edge
it's yeah this movie is like completely
ridiculous supposed to be this but it is
super super fun and we had like just a
great time watching I thought it was
hysterical so if you go into that with
with that mindset yeah um you know it's
a it's it's a really good horror comedy
it's not you know probably not as good
as something like Tucker and Dale vs.
evil or something like that but it's in
that kind of yeah it was sexuality I'm
not sure there was even nudity in this
was it I don't remember I don't think
there was now so you know booty poppin
and [ __ ] like that
fate strip teases and and that kind of
thing yeah couple of these two girls
were kind of making out and then it made
fun of that just funny yeah it's just a
funny like like I said just very lowbrow
like eighty is kind of like ridiculous
over-the-top humor and I thought it was
a blast so if that sounds like your cup
of tea then you should check it out
you
so the next thought I wanted to talk
about was also on Netflix and it's a
Thai movie and it's called crush you
yeah human kiss now before we get to
that there was something about girls
with balls that I meant to mention and I
forgot to mention it when we were just
talking about girls with balls and that
was that the guy who directed it I think
this was his directorial debut but
before that he had been the special
effects guy on the very very good French
cannibal film raw which used to be on
Netflix I don't know if it's still in
there anymore but if you haven't seen it
you should go check it out it's
excellent and he also did the effects on
knife and heart which is on shudder at
the moment which is a very very weird
like horror me I liked it but I can see
how it would be kind of polarizing
alright so the next one we're gonna talk
about like I said is called inhuman kiss
and it is a Thai movie from 2019 yeah
and this is okay we saw this in just by
random I just saw this as watch that one
well yeah cuz I said oh there's a 2019
let's watch that one so but what I
hadn't heard anything about it or
anything
not a bad movie not a bad news I don't
know though I mean it has horror
elements to it but I would almost call
it a romance a love story
yeah it's I've seen it called a romance
horror and I would agree with that yeah
it's actually about across you which you
know in Thai folklore is a female demon
who I guess she's possessed by a demon
and then her head comes off and it was
like and it flies around with all the
organs hanging down and stuff and then
it goes like eats cattle and Jen this is
up it's old-school yeah I imagined I
feel like a lot of Asian cultures have
similar it's I would call almost like a
Thai vampire it is kind of but they she
doesn't they don't attack humans though
I think he's I think they said that in
the movie they just attacked like cows
and chickens which of course in a
village where people are raising cows
and chickens that's still gonna be
probably at his dudes girlfriend comes
down with her head separates and goes
flying off and one day some guys show up
and they're kind of like vampire hunters
from Thailand hunt across you hunters
it's a big [ __ ] gang of them they got
guns and special tools and they've got
all these [ __ ] shrunken heads because
every time they kill one of them the
kind of
deserve the head and yeah they're
they're after boys girlfriend because
she's one of them and yeah trying to
figure out how to protect her and keep
her from getting in trouble with this
[ __ ] you know she's pretty depressed
about it
it's weird I like the effects that about
how it was separating to just black
stuff start growing around her neck and
then it the head would fall off but the
way they shot it it's almost kind of
g-rated so you couldn't actually ever
see a headless body and they always kind
of hid the point of separation where the
head comes off the body yeah I don't I
think there might have been something in
Thailand to where to try to keep the
film ratings right yeah it showed a
headless I think the only time they
showed her headless body was like at the
end like when he was carrying it to the
boat like yeah always a certain way
where you never see the incision yeah I
never saw the stump like I said I think
they just they just showed it very very
briefly and like at the very end when he
was carrying her body to the boat yeah I
thought it was alright I thought I was
gonna go somewhere but then as it as the
story started unfolding starting to get
kind of sappy yeah like I said this is
almost like it is a horror movie it's
it's gory and it's got like a lot of
it's a you know it's a monster movie
yeah but basically the core of it is
this girl who's the center of the story
her name is psy and she is across you
but it's it's kind of like a story of
her and like this love triangle between
her and these two boys that loved her
and there one of them has joined up with
the hunters and one of them is like
trying to protect her and like you're
not sure what their motivations are
because she's such a nice girl and she
can't help it she just she got the curse
when she was a kid and there's nothing
she can do about it she just like she
falls asleep and every night and like
her head comes off and starts running
around doing [ __ ] yeah and so it
I liked that aspect of the story because
that's something that they don't you
don't have here well it's something that
they don't really one that's a cool
monster cuz like I said we don't really
have an equivalent of that yeah it's
flying through the air and the hair is
kind of like it's kind of pink and it's
like tentacles and it looks good it did
it looked really great
like it really likes the cross you a fan
ahead it go underneath stuff they try to
grab
fight with it and her tentacles could
like pullin on it yeah you know she
could like touch people with his and her
hair was kind of going like that like
seeking water good you know yeah it's
pretty good I mean it's you know it's
not the best but it's better than like
some sci-fi original movie that's for
sure yes we're talking about Thailand
yeah you know it's pretty good you know
for yeah I'm sure like Thailand you know
Thailand isn't really known for real
high budget movies I mean yeah back when
we were kids this would have been some
[ __ ] ridiculous dubbed like kung foo
like a movie you know with like the
conqueror like plaster really moved up
in the world for us filmmaking I think
in Thailand like I said the only thing
I'm really I didn't like about is it
reminded me of a lot of Korean movies
you know having lived in Korea you come
across Korean movies especially back in
the 80s they were got very sappy and
mopey and emo and they you know Koreans
like to cry over [ __ ] the crowd of [ __ ]
that you know that an American wouldn't
cry over you know oh my god they love
that [ __ ] back then and you know you
kind of show that to an American
audience or like okay he's crying come
on we're next
come on hurry up yeah yeah we don't
[ __ ] wallow in it and this movie was
[ __ ] wall away it did seem a little
bit like uh or not lie a little bit and
it seemed a lot like a soap opera in
parts like there were some very very
long scenes like between psy and like
one of the one of the two dudes
their names were Jordan Noi and uh you
know when they would just like give
meaningful glances usual I read this one
review of it and the what and the woman
that reviewed it actually liked it but
she said they should make a drinking
game out of like every time there's a
scene where the two characters are just
like looking significantly idiot it's
edited for a different culture that has
yeah the cultural standards on how
they're gonna tell story you know I mean
I guess you could say Americans are kind
of changed to that kind of stuff well
we're very impatient but like so one
thing I didn't realize until I read some
reviews of this which I guess it didn't
really occur to me but it was actually
supposed to be said in 1941 like when
the Japanese were invading because they
mentioned a couple times that Bangkok
was getting bombed and stuff like that
and I guess I didn't really think about
it cuz I was kind of sleeping
we were watching that I was 41 yeah this
must be night today you really couldn't
tell
yeah I couldn't really tell him I guess
I didn't really cuz I did you know I
didn't know about I just lived in that
the girl lived in a village you know and
I suppose they're still round out in
Thailand where it's just kind of a
raised platform with a roof it didn't
really have any walls bad and but it was
furnished you know yeah because you know
it's [ __ ] hot there yeah so you're
not yet what they usually just have
curtains instead of walls yeah you know
I get that like fats or something like
that
yes that's roof yeah I I think they just
use kind of like curtains and and stuff
to make rooms yeah you know the polls
polls in the inside but it was actually
kind of nice little I don't know what
you call it some kind of little Thai
look like place you have a vacation in
or something like a vacation and resort
yeah that didn't it yeah like something
Dave Bowie might own private island sir
but yeah I didn't realize so like I said
if you're kind of into I mean it it's a
good looking movie like the
cinematography is really nice and
everything I feel like it could have
been like half an hour shorter cuz it's
al it's two hours or a little over two
hours didn't even and they probably
could I mean just for American audiences
because we're like impatient as [ __ ]
over here and it's like they could have
and even me and I love you know you guys
know I love slow burn horror movies all
sit there and watch that [ __ ] all day
long but even this I think I kind of
dozed off a couple times like like
during some of the like soapy scenes and
where they were like you know crying
each other it's like a monster yet I
think I've got a dinner 45 minutes out
of this movie yeah you probably could
have I would be a fast paced kind of
interesting movie but the ending of it
was pretty cool like it
I feel like it was like soap opera soap
operas and then like the last half hour
it was like a big it had an action one
in blow out a bunch of monsters demons
fightin so yeah it's cut it's
interesting to see like from a different
like cultural standpoint like that
because to us that would seem like like
a weird tonal shift but I guess it's to
them it didn't seem like that yet I
demons fighting each but yeah so it's
almost like a tragedy because like I
said she's a likable character and you
know she can't help what she is and she
has all these people like trying to kill
her and then people trying to protect
her and stuff like that so I likes that
aspect of it because you don't get a lot
of horror movies that are like that
show the monster sympathetic I didn't
really get the idea or the feeling that
she was the undead either now like an
infected person well she was cursed yeah
like a cursed person because they showed
at the beginning that she went into that
like old abandoned house where they said
oh there's a crush you was in there and
stuff like that and it gate and it
passed the curse on to her that's
through a kiss that's what it's inhuman
kids it like it floated out of the box
and kissed her and then she got it
I think I can kind of recommend a movie
just as a study of monsters from another
culture it was kind of fun to watch yeah
like I said you don't see a lot of one's
about crush you because we don't really
have that and there's something very
inherently cool about someone's head
coming off around with all them yeah
there's gonna be some slow moments and
some emo moments but yeah keep in mind
that it's it's it gets very soapy at
some times and like you know if you get
sick of it you can kind of like
fast-forward through that point but like
other than that it was like pretty good
I think it could have been edited down
some but other than that I have kind of
enjoyed it maybe I'll rewatch it again
when I'm not so sleepy next time and I
might enjoy it better the second time
all right now just as I said at the
beginning of the show this week was one
of the very awesome RiffTrax live yeah
if you guys don't know about these van
check them out
AMC runs them they del pick some theater
and they'll just do a riff track on some
old movie and you get to watch it live
in your your theater the crowds in them
are pretty good yeah they always they
usually do them from I can't rember the
name of the theater but they always do
it from one in Nashville which I guess
it's like a smaller theater and they
always have like a big they show like
outside like all the fans waiting and
you know all the decoration and the
lobby and everything like that so they
kind of go all out but yeah this is one
theater in Nashville and then they just
show it like all over the country
yeah and AMC lets you drink in there
they got a bar yeah so you know if you
want to drink if you want to sneak your
own is more economical but yeah this one
was giant spider invasion with yes house
a little kids gonna shout out of me it
was about six
my dad was laughing that it was scary
really hey watch it yeah yeah yeah the
thing about this one I was really really
excited when I heard that they were
doing giant spider invasion because if
you guys know they did MST did it back
in season eight or season nine I can't
remember and that was like really one of
the best episodes because this movie is
like it's one of those ones it's so so
terrible it's like so so cheaply made
but it is so so so the entertaining so
bad it's good
it is so entertaining I mean just the
characters at the center of it are just
like so horrible Alan Hale also known as
the skipper Ellis in it his last movie
like telling his dumbass dad jokes and
yeah with his huge belly and the first
time you see him he said he's just in
damn copy and Rizzo buddy so that's his
first night in the movie every Bale and
everybody's like uh but that's pretty
good it's just absolutely nonsensical
story about something like a big falling
meteor type thing that's the earth and
somehow b-52s involved and NASA gets
involved with that and they figure out
never that it wasn't that it was
a meteor it was a black hole and then it
landed near the house of a bunch of
inbred [ __ ] hillbillies always
company Wisconsin who it's like to dude
with his wife and then his sister-in-law
and he's trying to crack them both is
like wearing these wearing overalls it
just it's hilarious dude it's hilarious
he's really he's like this
tubby lookin like ol guy this is craggly
beard and i think we think he's the
director too well I think that he either
wrote the story or directed it like I
said um Bill Rebane is his name and I
say I believe that he went on to a
pretty successful career later on is
like an accent coach or something like
that I think he was on like Carson and
[ __ ] by the other day but he's just like
chooses to portray himself in this movie
yes this this dumpy child molesting like
disgusting he's like nachos you know but
going after like super young what he was
saying I liked you back when you were 11
so Travis what are you doing to her
though it's just he was just thinking
and what it was it was makeup what they
were doing is they were making fun of
hillbillies yeah because why would it
was funny though it was funny it was
that you could tell that they were
trying to make it comedic I mean like
obviously this dude is like it's so
gross yeah and he's just like everyone
in town he's walking around in these red
long johns with like stains on the back
like you he'd himself yeah and he's got
like this yucky like backbrace all the
time and they're showing him like and
he's banging like the waitress at the
brezza there's also german hookers and
it's just like this ridiculous and he's
like the main character and he's a cop
and then his wife is like a total
alcoholic yeah she's just like calling
the data from the restaurants on her
bring booze over tonight yeah like girl
trying to screw each other there and
then somehow on this on this hillbillies
farm he finds all these cows all dead
you know eaten up by something and then
they're finding these geodes that open
up and they have thrashing around so
then the next thing you know people
started getting attacked by damn
trashing this the size of a puppy dog
and then later
tarantula the size of a horse and then
they see a damn tranche Allah that's
probably about 40 feet long I mean it's
huge it's just bigger than a house gets
on top of the house starts busting
houses down it runs through the fair
chases all little kids crashing cars in
the [ __ ]
they're shooting at it it's just it was
a good movie I mean when you think about
how cheap this movie was yeah okay they
must have had a lot of fun filming this
[ __ ] especially the end looks like they
had a lot of fun where the whole town is
just time to transfer transformed into a
gun-wielding militia out trying to get
to LA yeah drunk a yelling and they're
actually fighting this gigantic fake
spider in the middle of downtown yeah
and they've fallen over she was pretty
good that looks like a parade float
looks like a parade look which i think
is what it is I think they just built a
big giant spider like over a car chassis
because I was looking for the wheels I
need to see it I think it was on a rod I
think the car was way behind it yeah
maybe yeah like a float maybe that maybe
that's how it was on a big boom because
it was out there on its own but it was
definitely moving like it was motor like
the legs were doing this but they
weren't really touching the ground that
my yeah not bad for probably like the
$50 that this movie and the science
behind the movie didn't make any damn
sense that they were making up sciences
Margo Hale was in this - she was like
actually kind of a big star name today
and yeah the the NASA people and the and
the other guy yeah it was at NASA and
the science woman besides woman Sashi
she worked at the observatory she was
there she was an astronomer it was hard
to tell it's hard to keep [ __ ] straight
yeah somehow or another a black hole
comes from outer space like a shooting
star yeah somehow or another [ __ ] up a
b-52 then they never really mentioned
what the be like I said they had had
they had stock footage of a b-52 said
they had - like she warned that into the
stories yeah get on that guy's farm and
when it hits something and when it hit
it actually bored a hole into another
universe where spiders were coming up
yeah the spider dimension which is
right next to ours and somehow or
another when this happened it killed a
guy who was on his dirt bike out in
there remember that even though he was
nowhere close to he was nowhere close to
it but then he was all chewed up like he
was eaten who didn't make any goddamn
sense it was just a an excuse to show
dead things yeah with like a little like
a very very clean skeleton hey yeah yeah
and stuff like that I have to mention
poor Alan Hale who was in this movie
that's like I said this might have been
his last movie correct me if I'm wrong
but pretty much other than his opening
line which was hey little buddy or
whatever reason to some other character
and it's like every in this movie okay I
think he was contractually obligated to
stay indoors to stay he's like can I
just film like 99% of my scenes just
sitting in this office on the phone
because I don't run go outside or walk
or anything that was 1950 style when you
were just you stayed in your office and
you talked on the phone with somebody
else yeah it was a whole movie about
talking on the phone yeah yeah he was
doing that and he was also taught he was
also in the the bar he was in the diner
didn't die on the bar yeah it's disome
scenes there so they moved him from that
scene to that scene yeah the only scene
and that was probably in the same
building
yeah I'm sure and the only scene where
they showed about sighs when he goes to
the Hillbillies ranch asking about the
motors ask about the motor he stood on
the porch for a few minutes and that was
that it's like okay that's outside
that's all outside in the the final
conflict in the big at the end when the
[ __ ] spider is sucking tearing up
downtown he's booked me the sheriff he
spends the whole time on the phone every
time yelling like if those people don't
get his shotgun he's getting a shotgun
ready to go fight in a Suzie
soon as he heads out to the door the
phone rings again which brings him back
so that they keep doing this phone thing
to keep him from actually leaving I
actually leave in the office which I the
Kevin and Bill and Myka the tracks guys
they had a field day with that because
like everything like it looked like he
was gonna go be a man of actually got a
shotgun and then like they're like let
the phone like please let the front
please let the phone work yes the office
yeah yeah so so you what you what happen
is is you get robbed of the final scene
were Alan Hale the skipper okay could go
out there with his shot
and finally fight and destroy this dam
yes spider working or buddy Leonard buy
it it never happened
we do get to season people yet now if
you've seen the version of this that
they did on mst3k many years ago I was
surprised it how much they cut out of
the movie I mean they cut stuff out of
the movie like for time obviously
because you know they only had like 90
minutes or 78 minutes or whatever it was
with the commercials but they also would
take it they had to take out nudity they
had to take out like excessive gore
although they would leave some gore in
there so there's like a lot of scenes
like the one seen with cousin Billy the
guy that works at the Rock Shop where he
comes over to the house and is like
leering at the yeah yeah sister and like
they do just like that shamelessly just
close-up on the tips so I was like
sitting there going oh my goodness well
and we're he's just like leering at this
girl like and all the creepy [ __ ] about
about Kester I think is that is the
character's name with the long johns and
the back brace yeah but um you know with
him like hitting on the sister that's
like his sister's know his wife's
younger sister yes is his sister-in-law
yes oh it's his sister-in-law right and
she actually at first it sounded like
she wanted him to dump her sister and go
with her and then she was a basic ended
up being like psych yes he was date in
high school guys she was a high school
girl yeah yeah that guy oh my god that
guy in there the young guy that had that
shirt the shirt that he's first wearing
to be I swear to god my dad had that
exact same shirt not in the 70s this
movie came out in 1978 I'm happy to
report that cuz I was kind of hoping 78
the movie did yeah damn that was older
than I thought I wasn't I'm sorry yeah I
was about eight years old so you
shouldn't have been scared by oh no I
made eight that's pretty yeah well I
mean if you're if you don't like spiders
I mean there's plenty of like real
tarantulas crawling you know it really
scared me though what it's when that
woman fell down and went next to that
damn cow head oh yeah yeah okay cuz that
was a real cat that freaks me out that
and from there on out okay and then the
lender thing with it when they blended a
lot of people talked about that yeah
because okay see now that's the kind of
thing where and you know what I think
even Stephen King mentioned this in
Danse Macabre where he's talking about
even even a movie as shitty as giant
spider invasion he's like that one
scene where the spider is in the blender
and shits really funny because you can
tell she's like pointedly not looking at
the water like what you but she's like
just going like this pouring some vodka
and the lining laughs I do see the
spider in there and then like [ __ ] you
know and then they have like this thing
where he's gonna drink it and he does a
drink you're like oh gross and it's like
even in the theater and we were seeing
it like the RiffTrax like people aback
were like oh you know the giant spider
never scared me it was all the little
ones well yeah yeah and that's because
they were real yeah another ones though
actually the the scene that was the
horse about the size of the spider that
jumped out of damn attic and jumped on
her yeah that one that one is oh and
that all happened like in a short period
of time yeah you know and the one she
got killed on a bar yeah that's what I
remember that movie the big the big
horse sighs yesterday sort of course yes
but pulled out sighs yeah like jumping
out of the loft oh yeah
but the the giant was [ __ ] like
happening downtown I like that as a kid
well yeah because that didn't look real
like I said it looked like a big parade
for you it looked like a big spider yeah
but I was gonna say that if you saw the
mst3k episode then you will be happy to
know because I was wondering they would
do this because one of the most famous
things that came out of that was like
particularly the end with all the like
drunken hillbillies running around with
those shotguns and everything and like
you know the MSC guys were just sit
there going Packers backers was Super
Bowl and all this other kind of crap and
like when we went to the RiffTrax thing
I noticed that Kevin Murphy had a
Packers jersey on even though it wasn't
a super obvious one but like the colors
and everything and I was like what were
they gonna do the Packers joke and they
did I was very very happy but other than
that I like that when they do these
RiffTrax live even if they do movies
that they did before on MSG because they
did time chasers they did mannose hands
of fate they did movies that they had
done on MSC before but they really
really try hard not to repeat any jokes
they'll do a callback every now and then
like if for people that remember the
episode but they really really tried to
do a new I just remained on it I just
remember that Alan Hale did eventually
get out of the office when did he leave
the office he tried to calm the crowd
down and it failed remember oh that's
right anything okay so he was
contractually obligated to outdoor scene
and that's
yeah the rest of town I'm just gonna sit
on my bed on the office and talk on the
phone he got on the CB and said you know
that I couldn't control that yeah
then it crap ran off he was on the
Philly police yeah yeah I'd love to know
like this story behind that because he's
like look I'm a big star I'm right here
in the [ __ ] parole Wisconsin with all
you Hicks like making this movie with
this stupid spider it's like just giving
my paycheck I'm just gonna sit in this
tapas set I've got to give the movie
props though they knocked down a house
they did okay they ran a car into a
couple cars up ran a car into a gas
station and they caught on fire it's an
abandoned gas station you could tell
yeah and then they wrecked two or three
cars downtown and they can they call
them fire
yes they actually did yes some real X
you know yeah starts so it wasn't like
it wasn't like one of those like 50s or
60s horror movies where it's just like a
bunch of people in lab coats Stadium and
in offices you're talking about how
horrifying oh yeah and they just put in
a little bit of stock footage it wasn't
that bad he actually gets rated
excellent yes and like you said I do
feel like even though I mean the jokes
in this or like you know obviously the
RiffTrax jokes are funny but like the
jokes in the actual movie which is like
painfully painfully bad they were just
like I'm we're funny though they were
like dead later like dad joke level kind
of stuff you know I was doing Alan hey
I'm talking about these prunes and like
keeping him regular and stuff yeah it's
like my grandpa I kind of think he I
kind of think he was add living I get
the feeling he was yeah he thought
everything was funny he laughed at
everything which I thought like the
RiffTrax guys had a lot of fun with that
too because it just seemed like they
would tell him like all this serious
[ __ ] he'd just be like ah ha ha like
make a [ __ ] joke yeah yeah how they
destroy the spider was weird NASA gave
them some kind of an bomb neutrino type
[ __ ] device they even said model 10
with a charge of a hundred grab one of
those yeah we got then put it in a
helicopter and the helicopter is calling
me they call a scientist do you want me
land to keep the trigger no you do it
then the dude throws the damn bomb and I
guess it landed on the spider or the
hole to the other dimension it never
made it clear and then the the and then
it didn't blow up it just she's a saw
smoke let's be honest yeah smoke and
then like the big spider was like the
spot again the caught on fire you could
tell they had some flares tied to it to
get the flight to fire to start and then
it started to melt like [ __ ] yeah I
can fried chicken gravy which is
probably one of the goofiest endings
other than maybe street trash but it
kind of reminded me of that and this
really just shows you have its ass
that's what I mean and it's like I I
knew that they probably couldn't make a
joke because one of the best jokes from
the original the MST when they did this
was servo just going does it matter that
the spider just rammed him up his butt
that's what it looked like it it'll look
like a mouth look like the spiders and
stuff like that so I knew they couldn't
make another joke about that but guys
spider actually didn't look that bad but
the flaw from close-up yeah the flaw in
the spider is that the spider had eyes
yeah they shouldn't have been
firefighters don't have eyes like they
would have just look better with Noah
but nothing there I mean I mean these
spiders do have eyes obviously but
they're little black dots on the top of
it yeah it's not like you big fly any
big old flies on the front which like I
didn't notice fighter look like rights
and they eyes on that spider yeah it's
just they look like two big red like
headlights is with it yeah like yeah
they were like they were like the eyes
of an ant they were yeah yeah or like I
said it was like a housefly yeah spiders
eyes don't I was gonna have compound
eyes they have symbolizing yeah but yeah
I was gonna say to like the one scene
where the one guy the other sheriff not
Alan Hale but where he was getting eaten
by the spider clearly that guy like the
spider was trying to pick him up because
obviously there were people inside there
like pulling him up in there and they
kept dropping him but it looked like he
kept getting up like he really wanted to
get eaten by somebody was trying to
crawl in there like they kept dropping
him and they kept all that [ __ ] in there
he's like no eBay baby so it's just like
really really funny but yeah a much more
if you didn't see our rib tracks because
now some of these RiffTrax live if you
don't see them in the theater they
usually do them to nights they'll do
them like on a Thursday night and I
think they do them like on a Tuesday
night or Wednesday night sometimes they
used to put them up several months later
they'd put them up on Hulu I've seen a
couple of them on to be so if you miss
them in the theater like sometimes they
won't put them up or you can go to the
RiffTrax website and they'll probably
tell you like where you can see them
afterward because I have watched some
that I missed in the theater like you
know a couple of other ones that from a
long time ago
I like to see them live in the theaters
more of a party atmosphere yeah it's
more fun because you're there with like
other bands and you know and it's a lot
more fun because these movies are just
like so ridiculous and this is actually
the best one I've seen a long time
because I was very familiar with this
movie from the MSC episode this one I
ever was man hands of fate yeah it's
hard to beat that one just because that
movie is just so good iconic that
Birdemic was pretty good too that's
pretty good too but David was really big
I remember like my [ __ ] face hurting
faster that man Birdemic [ __ ] heavy
rolling like man we were good for damage
I think we were dying
I think Birdemic might have been even
funnier cuz that movie was so
unconfident yeah it was totally
incompetent and you could tell then and
I think I've mentioned this before but
the best bad movies are where the people
think that they're making a good baby
yeah that dude that made it was like a
Chinese American guy who is like big
into the green movement and everything
yeah somehow solar panels were involved
yeah I understand that [ __ ] a company
that made solar panels I think I think
yeah they probably put up the money I
would advise yeah he he thought this was
a masterpiece and when you see the
special effects in this it's just it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
well why do you think it's you you're
dead oh yeah why do you think it's
become I mean it's just like Tommy
Wiseau in the room it's just this guy is
obviously an alien who doesn't know
anything about human emotions or how to
make a movie or anything and yet he had
all this money and he made a movie and
it's the craziest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen I gotta see this oh my gosh
but but he thought that it was a good
that's what I mean so I really think
like if you know if you're intentionally
making a bad movie sometimes that can
work but I don't think it usually works
I think you at least have to have
you have to have some measure that
you're taking it seriously because then
that like earnestness comes across and
makes it much funnier yeah
so the giant spider invasion I'm not
sure that they thought they were making
a good movie
they were having fun but they were just
having a good time and that kind of
comes across on screen yeah all the all
the characters are like so loathsome and
ridiculous but when it comes to rip
tracks I think the granddaddy of them
all was bird amic yeah now that I
mentioned yeah I think I remember
laughter now this is probably like going
to but this is this is pretty close
because I remember cracking up but a lot
of Manos is close to her dammit yeah I
know now I'm just now I'm gonna see if
like cuz maybe they have it on to me
after good you know I have to go watch
Birdemic again the RiffTrax [ __ ] I love
is they just called it over and over
again like how [ __ ] up that movie was
yeah yeah well these guys have been
doing this for all of their professional
lives so they're good at this couch yeah
making fun of the edits to the [ __ ]
camera angles and change this [ __ ] yeah
Mike still makes jokes about solar
panels yes or if it's all about solar
panels but yeah so next time RiffTrax
life comes to a theater near you you
should definitely go check them out
because they're very very funny and
they're super fun I mean you know if
you're an MST fan and you like that kind
of thing I mean who's not everybody
loves MST come on
so go check them out next time
[Music]